Trascrizione: Toti Di Dio
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
Da bambino volevo fare il progettista.
Questa foto testimonia che dico la verità.
A dire il vero, volevo
anche fare il calciatore di punizioni,
il vecchio saggio e il netturbino.
Poi, devo dire,
per quanto fosse interessante,
nonostante fosse divertente fare goal,
raccontare storie,
girare tutta la notte
aggrappato a un camion,
nonostante tutte queste cose
molto interessanti
essere nato a Palermo negli anni Ottanta
mi ha dato un'enorme voglia
di provare a cambiare il mondo.
Come si fa a progettare un mondo migliore?
Non lo so
Ho cercato di trovare risposte
andando un po’ in giro qua e là.
Alla fine, la idea
più ragionevole
era quella di provare
a progettare città migliori,
perché guardando un po' di dati,
le città sono
una minuscola percentuale
sulla superficie del Pianeta, tipo il 2%,
dove vivono più del 50%
degli abitanti della Terra
e dove si consumano tantissime risorse,
si inquina tantissimo.
Allora provare ad affrontare
quel tipo di problema lì
può essere un modo per cambiare
effettivamente il destino del mondo.
Città intelligenti, capaci di rispondere
alle esigenze degli esseri umani
appagando i nostri sogni,
le noste ambizioni,
le nostre necessità,
ma nel rispetto del Pianeta.
Più andavo dritto verso questo modo
di pensare il futuro
più mi rendevo conto che in realtà,
avere città proprio come queste
significa costruire
il privilegio per alcuni.
Perché se davvero vogliamo provare
ad affrontare il problema
dobbiamo guardare altrove.
Un futuro un po più complicato.
Provare a rendere
queste città intelligenti.
Viviamo in un universo,
in un mondo costruito,
il Sud globale è la sfida.
Perché queste città,
l'80% di queste città stanno al Sud
ed è generalmente per il sud globale
una condizione di privazione di risorse,
di diritti, di opportunità.
Generalmente lo stato è quello
di costante emergenza,
di risposte immediate,
che davvero migliorano
le condizioni giornaliere.
Ma come si fa, anche qui, non lo so.
Sicuramente i metodi
utilizzati fino a oggi
non funzionano,
ci hanno portato a questa eredità.
Nell'arco di questa generazione,
più di tre miliardi di persone
vivranno in queste città,
dobbiamo inventarci qualcosa.
Proviamo a cambiare punto di vista,
proviamo a vedere le cose
sotto un'altra luce.
A sinistra c'è un pezzo di questo pianeta
fortemente urbanizzato,
che ha tutta l'aria di essere
del tutto impenetrabile e intrasformabile,
a destra c'è quel sistema nervoso
che anima questo tessuto.
In realtà è proprio un pezzettino
di sistema nervoso,
perché è la visualizzazione
di alcune interazioni via social network.
Ecco, città e cittadini
sono l'uno l'immagine dell'altro,
lo diceva pure Platone,
e se è ancora vero,
e oggi sembra essere ancora vero,
noi possiamo provare a interagire
con queste persone,
con coloro che fanno la città.
Possiamo provare a curare il tessuto
attraverso questo sistema nervoso.
La città è fatta
dalla scelte dei cittadini,
dalle loro abitudini.
Possiamo provare a inserirci là dentro,
cambiando le loro esperienze,
aumentate con le nuove tecnologie,
che ci consentono di percepire
la realtà in un modo nuovo, diverso,
spesso migliore della realtà stessa.
È una questione di percezione.
È possibile farlo?
Io ho il privilegio di lavorare
con dei ragazzi straordinari
in un laboratorio di design,
dove proviamo a dare delle risposte
a queste domande.
Oggi vi presento tre soluzioni
che abbiamo immaginato
in uno di questi contesti ai margini
dei processi di globalizzazione, Palermo.
Non è un caso che sono palermitano,
a Palermo sono tornato.
Palermo e il Sud, in questo caso,
nonostante tutto
diventano il luogo perfetto
per provare a trovare strumenti nuovi.
Se funziona a Palermo,
funziona dappertutto.
Allora iniziamo con l'affrontare
uno dei problemi più gravi,
il "traffico" come spesso viene definito.
Certo, non sono il primo
e non sarò neanche l'ultimo
a utilizzare questa, a vedere questo
come una metafora dello stare a Palermo.
Grandissimi artisti l'hanno fatto
e in effetti la realtà
spesso supera la fantasia.
Palermo è davvero
una città super-trafficata.
Siamo terzi, secondo alcune classifiche.
Siamo terzi, dietro soltanto
a Mosca e Istanbul.
Però se andiamo proprio a guardarla,
qualcosa non va perché
la città è piccola
e il numero di macchine è enorme,
la densità è alta.
Dovremmo essere sicuramente i primi,
se poi andiamo a vedere
quanto i palermitani
amano andare in macchina.
Il 78% dei trasporti,
dei tragitti giornalieri
sono fatti in macchina.
Ragazzi di Mosca e Istanbul,
attenti, perché ora schizziamo noi
in prima posizione.
Comunque, a parte queste classifiche
dell'infamia
è chiaro che il traffico
non è il problema della nostra città,
è il problema di tante città.
Io penso che nel sud del mondo
i problemi principali
siano sempre legati a corruzione e mafia,
ma sicuramente il traffico è castrante
per lo sviluppo di una città.
La difficoltà di collegarsi,
una città non accessibile
è una città che non dà diritti.
Oltre a questo, chiaramente
è un problema legato alle risorse.
Produrre auto,
consumare energie non rinnovabili
È una minaccia per l'ambiente,
per la sicurezza
degli abitanti delle città.
Che si fa?
Si migliorano i mezzi
di trasporto pubblico,
di trasporto di massa,
si fanno le metro.
Però, generalmente, specie in contesti
molto storicizzati come i nostri,
quando si scava si trova un’anfora,
i cantieri durano tanto.
Poi, rimane il problema
della corruzione.
Questi cantieri durano tantissimo,
poi quando finalmente finiscono
le città sono completamente diverse,
sono cambiate.
Perché le città sono fatte da loro,
cittadini che hanno lasciato
a casa la macchina
e sperano prima o poi
di lasciare anche la fermata,
o quelli che ogni giorno da veri eroi
sfidano questi mostri di 2 tonnellate
con le biciclettine.
Allora se è questa l'esperienza
di muoversi in modo diverso,
sostenibile nei confronti del pianeta,
in città,
allora non abbiamo dove andare
perché è chiaro che
non è possibile convincere
quel 78% a cambiare le proprie abitudini.
Allora, che facciamo?
Proviamo a guardare la cosa
da un altro punto di vista.
Allora, abbiamo detto che è una sfida
impegnativa per se stessi,
perché ci si scontra con la città
e alla fine non c'è nessun premio.
Se arrivo in bicicletta alla posta
non c'è qualcuno mi fa festa.
però se proviamo a ripartire da questo:
è una sfida che richiede impegno
e potrebbe, dovrebbe richiedere un premio.
Mia nonna diceva: se fai il bravo,
alla fine c'è pane e marmellata.
Benissimo! Facciamo un gioco,
è un gioco muoversi in città,
è un gioco se si usano soltanto
mezzi di trasporto sostenibile.
Muoversi a piedi, in bicicletta,
con i mezzi pubblici, car sharing/pooling.
E allora, questa è un'applicazione
per smartphone che dà informazioni
rispetto al costo, in termini di
tempo, energia, e di costo economico
quanto costa muoversi
con un mezzo rispetto all'altro,
ma mentre ci si muove si fanno punti,
secondo il mezzo di trasporto utilizzato.
Questi punti attivano delle sfide.
Cosa si vince? Premi!
Veri e propri premi messi a disposizione
da una rete di sponsor locali,
aziende piccole e medie
che hanno tutto l’interesse
a ravvivare la mobilità sostenibile,
perché se ci muove a piedi,
coi mezzi cosiddetti lenti,
si ha anche il tempo per fare la spesa,
oltre a non inquinare la città ovviamente.
E allora, per loro diventa uno strumento
per conoscere meglio i propri clienti
e avere un accesso diverso
al rapporto con i cittadini.
Noi abbiamo fatto diversi test,
abbiamo preso a campione l'Università
degli Studi di Palermo e i suoi ragazzi,
abbiamo preso un campione di questi
e abbiamo fatto molte sperimentazioni.
Il risultato finale è stato incredibile,
almeno da come eravamo partiti,
perché ovviamente tutti dicevano:
a Palermo nulla farete!
alla fine l'applicazione ha avuto
una redemption
da buona applicazione di intrattenimento.
I ragazzi hanno effettivamente
migliorato le proprie abitudini,
minimizzando il loro impatto del 50%
come se ci fossero le targhe alterne,
ma senza alcun semaforo in più,
nessuna multa, nessun vigile,
nessuna videocamera.
Li abbiamo fatti giocare,
gli abbiamo dato un motivo valido,
abbiamo trovato diversi motivi validi per
far interagire diversamente i cittadini .
I ragazzi uscivano da casa al grido
"Andiamo a fare punteggio!"
e ci hanno provato in tutti i modi
a fregarci
per prendersi i premi
senza muoversi in modo sostenibile,
ma questo a noi, ovviamente
è servito per cercare di
blindare il gioco e le regole del gioco.
Un' altra cosa interessante
che siamo riusciti a ottenere
attraverso questo nuovo strumento
sono i dati,
partendo da una città che ha chiaramente
un problema legato al traffico,
dati rispetto a un tipo di mobilità
diverso, sostenibile.
Noi oggi sappiamo, almeno per il campione
che abbiamo analizzato,
qual'è la strada migliore per raggiungere
in bicicletta un dipartimento o l'altro
o quella da fare a piedi, o quale linea
dell'autobus ha più problemi,
magari durante
un certo periodo del giorno.
Certo in città non ci si muove
solo per andare a lavoro
o all'università.
Ci si muove anche per cose bellissime
come queste,
quindi per quello che riguarda il turismo
e che spesso è un driver importante
in contesti come il nostro.
Ora succede spesso che si incontrino
poveri turisti tedeschi
con i calzini e i sandali,
girare come zombie in vicoli come questo,
che sono distanti appena 500 metri
dalla Cappella Palatina
e sono completamente persi,
anelano informazioni,
semplicemente dove andare,
nel momento giusto possibilmente,
e che magari qualcuno gli desse
un consiglio su un itinerario.
Che si fa?
Segnaletica, si prova a dare informazioni
nel modo classico,
però questo richiede
dei costi di manutenzione,
allora si prendono i bambini e
si spargono per la città,
facendo da ciceroni.
A me l'hanno fatto fare,
una frustrazione terribile.
Allora immaginiamo un'esperienza
diversa per visitare la città.
Servono informazioni e ci sono spesso,
li chiamano OPEN DATA,
spesso non sono così raffinati
come vorremmo,
per cui è un lavoro
veramente da scavatore,
per cui serve anche una comunità
che riesca a tenere aggiornati i dati
legati al patrimonio storico-artistico.
Esistono già comunità
che offrono il proprio tempo
per cercare di migliorare
l'accoglienza della propria città,
e poi serve un po’ di matematica
per cercare,
in tutte queste informazioni complesse,
di offrirle in un modo semplice,
per esempio,
l'algoritmo dei Percorsi Minimi
del Prof. Dijkstra è un inizio.
Allora cosa abbiamo fatto?
Mettendo insieme Open Data,
una comunità e un po’ di matematica,
il prof. Dijkstra,
è venuto fuori uno strumentino.
Uno strumento che consente
di avere l’informazione giusta
nel momento giusto offline,
in tutte le città.
Perché in tutte le città?
L'applicazione è completamente OPEN,
sono open i dati, è open il codice.
Ogni comunità può candidarsi
e inserire il proprio database
in questo modo dota di fatto
la propria città dell'applicazione.
Questo è un tentativo di cercare
di migliorare la nostra ospitalità
e cercare di migliorare
l'ospitalità di tante città del mondo.
Ora è chiaro che il virtuale
aiuta il reale
e non è soltanto
fare il figo durante eventi,
social o altro.
Può avere un impatto molto più importante
e si può applicare anche alla città.
Questa è una foto
di un quartiere sfortunato di Palermo,
ma potrebbe essere stata scattata
in qualsiasi altro posto del mondo.
Borgo Vecchio ha vari problemi,
conflitti sociali,
una fortissima evasione scolastica.
Ma ultimamente noi,
girando per questo quartiere
abbiamo visto roba strana,
bambini con gatti blu,
renne impazzite,
piovre malinconiche.
Tutta attività di un'associazione
che fa laboratori con i bambini
dopo scuola
e uno street artist, Ema Jons.
Lui con una pazienza invidiabile,
devo dirvi,
fa dipingere i bambini
dentro il laboratorio
e poi li porta fuori
a portare sul muro di casa loro,
di casa dei loro amici,
dei parenti, con l'aiuto degli amici,
dei parenti
e cambia qualche millimetro
della superficie dell'immobile,
innescando un processo
che ravviva davvero l'identità del luogo.
Identità della comunità
che è un vero processo di rigenerazione
dal basso,
ma proprio dai bassi perché
sono proprio bambini piccoli, bassi.
Oltre ad innescare quello che
può essere un sviluppo diverso
e davvero sostenibile,
perché fatto dalla comunità
per la comunità.
Una cosa straordinaria!
Dov'è il problema?
Che sono finiti i soldi.
L'associazione non ha più risorse
per poter continuare i laboratori.
Allora che si fa?
Dovrebbe essere qualcosa
curata dalla pubblica amministrazione,
però la pubblica amministrazione
ha finito i soldi,
allora anche l'esperienza
di trasformare la città,
che dovrebbe essere
compito da pubblica amministrazione,
si può trasformare
in un'esperienza diversa.
Noi abbiamo provato a raccontare
nel modo migliore possibile
quello che potevamo fare,
come se fosse un gioco da ragazzi
innescare un cambiamento
profondo per la città.
È come un processo giusto,
un po’ di colore e fantasia,
i luoghi cambiano, danno speranza.
Quindi abbiamo fatto una campagna
di crowdfunding,
come se stessimo vendendo
l'ultimo gingillo tecnologico
con perk straordinari
e super personalizzati,
abbiamo fatto un video
tradotto in dieci lingue,
non pensavo neanche esistessero,
ma ci siamo fatti aiutare
da amici sparsi in giro per il mondo
e questa campagna di crowfunding
è stata vista in 85 paesi.
I palermitanial'estero,
di prima, seconda o terza generazione
dovevano sapere cosa stava succedendo
nella sua città e dare una mano.
In poche settimane
abbiamo raggiunto l'obiettivo,
l'abbiamo superato,
siamo arrivati a più del 160%
e questo ci ha consentito
di attivare nuovi laboratori
anche con nuovi artisti
che sono venuti a Borgo Vecchio
e lavorato con i ragazzini.
Abbiamo lavorato con la loro passione,
anche, che è il calcio.
Quindi forza Palermo
anche se siamo a Catania,
mi consentirete di farlo.
E quindi abbiamo rimesso a posto
anche il campetto di calcio
che era un luogo
in cui la comunità si aggrega,
ovviamente non solo per il calcio
perché è una delle poche piazze lì.
Anche qui il lavoro fatto
dagli artisti con i ragazzi.
Borgo Vecchio si sta aprendo
a nuovi contatti con,
intanto, la città di Palermo
e poi con il mondo.
Oggi vengono artisti a fare opere
a Borgo Vecchio,
a vedere cosa succede a Borgo Vecchio.
Ed è, credo, il modo più giusto
per portare un cambiamento progressivo.
Voglio concludere il mio intervento
con questo graffito
che racconta come
la comunità di Borgo Vecchio
abbia tagliato le barriere
che la separavano dal mondo.
Come vedete ci sono tutti, c'è pure
un Pokémon e un uomo a forma di cuore.
Ogni trasformazione deve
tenere al centro le persone.
Quelle cose fatte di carne, ossa,
sentimenti, emozioni.
Se non ci sono al centro le persone
nessuna trasformazione
su questo territorio può funzionare.
Noi dobbiamo progettare
per il Sud e con il Sud.
Noi dobbiamo avere il coraggio
di saltare recinti,
spingerci dove possiamo fallire
perché altrimenti
non riusciremo mai
a progettare il nostro futuro.
Grazie a tutti!
(Applausi)